- C'est le nouveau café branché
de Tokyo. Des robots humanoïdes
accueillent et servent
les clients. Ils sont équipés
de caméras et de micros pour
recevoir les commandes.
Ces robots sont en fait
l'avatar d'employés qui
les contrôlent à distance.
Des personnes à mobilité réduite
travaillent de la maison.
Le robot présente l'employé
aux clients.
"Comme le Japon a un grave
problème de vieillissement de
la population, explique-t-il,
nous espérons permettre aussi
aux personnes âgées de continuer
à travailler de la maison."
Il s'agit d'une initiative
des laboratoires japonais de
robotique Ory, afin de créer
une société plus accessible.
Ces vidéos sont virales.
Le robot est une des vedettes de
l'aréna de basketball olympique.
Celui-ci livre le ballon du
match au rugby. Et d'autres,
semblables à lui, aident à
récupérer les disques et
javelots au stade d'athlétisme.
Les olympiques de Tokyo espèrent
être une vitrine exceptionnelle
pour l'innovation et la vision
futuriste nippone.
Le projet Robots,
un partenariat avec le géant
Toyota, a pour ambition que
ces Jeux soient les plus
novateurs. Ce n'est pas
pour rien que les mascottes
officielles sont des robots
inspirés par les bandes
dessinées manga.
Les organisateurs espèrent que
la technologie développée pour
les Olympiques sera utile au
quotidien. La combinaison à
assistance mécanique servant
au transport de matériel sur
les sites olympiques pourrait
l'être. Les employés qui
soulèvent de lourdes charges
dans les aéroports pourraient
s'en servir.
L'accessibilité universelle,
c'est la vision du comité
organisateur des Jeux de Tokyo.
Dans ce café qui partage cette
conception du monde, il est déjà
possible d'avoir un aperçu
du futur.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, T